[Musique]
si la contrepensive ukrainienne a pris
de courts les troupes russes l'étendue
de son succès à tout autant surpris ses
soldats ukrainiens
on est monté à l'assaut on a capturé une
position on l'a occupé on l'a fortifiait
trois jours plus tard le front a avancé
et ils ont commencé à décompter on se
tenait prêt à combattre alors imaginez
qu'ils allaient quitter tout seul
l'ensemble du front ça vraiment on ne
l'avait pas prévu
des soldats Ukrainiens savent à remettre
en marche le matériel abandonné par
l'ennemi
et ça va aller pour le roulement
c'est la nouvelle génération de
véhicules Oural russes qu'ils avaient
préparé pour l'invasion et bien
maintenant ils vont travailler pour nous
la déroute de l'armée russe se constate
partout ces soldats tout juste arrivé
pour sécuriser le territoire découvre
les anciennes positions russes
les lignes Russes se sont disloquées ici
ne reste que Lénine une pin-up et des
journaux de style soviétique sans
mauvaise nouvelle
l'histoire de ce succès tactique de
commandant accepte de nous en parler
leurs paroles est rare André Malakoff
est officier dans les Forces Spéciales
il a été blessé par balle pendant
l'opération selon lui cette réussite
tient d'abord à la ruse imaginée par
l'état-major ukrainien quelques semaines
avant l'offensive
j'ai dirigé la saut
ma manœuvre principale était la
diversion au sud de ballaklia
en fait
la plus grosse percée s'est faite par
l'Ouest
mais le renseignement a répondu partout
l'information
que l'attaque aurait lieu au sud
ils ont donc envoyé beaucoup de troupes
au sud
a commencé
on en a tué 200
toutes leurs tentatives de
contre-attaques ont été repoussées
ils s'en souviendront longtemps
la règle dans les manuels de tactiques
c'est que pour attaquer il faut être
trois fois plus nombreux que l'ennemi là
nous étions trois fois moins
une opération audacieuse basée sur une
manœuvre s'enfoncer en territoire ennemi
sur une longue distance
lorsque le plan lui est présenté hier au
slave va saluke a du mal à le croire il
commande une batterie de lance-roquette
multiple
donc ils nous ont briffés sur le plan et
ça nous a paru fou
j'ai attaqué j'avais des sentiments
partagés parce qu'il ne pouvait pas
juste avoir sorti un plan complètement
aberrant de leur chapeau
donc se devait tout de même être
réalisable
sur le papier ça pouvait être réalisé
mais c'était tellement audacieux c'était
c'était hyper cool
et quand je suis allé voir mes hommes
je leur ai dit à moitié en rigolant on
va mourir
son unité est désormais impatiente de
poursuivre cette contre-offensive
j'espère que ça va continuer
je ne suis pas sûr que ce soit aussi
rapide ou que les prochaines phases
soient déclenchées dans l'immédiat
en ce qui concerne le moral l'une des
conséquences du succès de cette
contre-attaque c'est que ceux qui n'ont
pas pu y prendre part sont encore plus
motivés pour travailler dur afin d'être
choisi pour les prochaines opérations
je leur dis toujours on a encore
tellement de territoires à libérer que
tout le monde aura sa chance de
participer à la libération d'un
territoire
mais il y a déjà une sorte de
compétition entre pour être inclus dans
la suite des opérations et je crois que
cela vient du succès de cette
contre-offensive
[Musique]
dans les territoires reconquis la tâche
n'est pas tout à fait finie ces soldats
viennent tout juste d'arriver à isium
c'est pas tranquille ici on ne sait pas
ce qui se passe dans les bois il n'y a
pas que nous ici il y en a qui se cache
on n'a pas fini le travail
des patrouilles
on nettoie les bois et les villages où
il y a encore ses
on appelle direct les services
un travail de fourmis puisque ce sont
des milliers de kilomètres de
territoires qui leur faut désormais
sécuriser